[Music]
if I spoke about it if I did even movies
that win Best Picture sometimes begin
with narration in this case drown
narration when I tell you about her
sounds like the story has a lot of
pronoun game implications so I would
rather not hear any of it
and the monster I'm trying to destroy it
all let me guess the monster was Michael
Shannon since his name appeared right
when you said that the water in the tub
is already almost at the top
look the Liza has time to wander out
into the living room then the kitchen
allowing for the establishing shot of
the theatre below then cook some eggs
before she gets in this floor should be
leaking well before it does later in the
movie eliza figures out the shape of
water in the first five minutes using
masturbation in an egg timer so why
should i watch the rest also magnetism
look I know Eliza doesn't have much
money and this room's in a rough area of
town but she's otherwise tidy and
fastidious you're telling me she hasn't
even attempted to paint the walls in
here or did she and the color she chose
was named Guillermo del Toro movie the
movie theater downstairs stores some of
their films in the apartment complex I
got to admit it's a great detail for the
production design but how much sense
does this make this may be set in the
middle of a metropolitan area known but
this is a ton of traffic for 11:00 p.m.
so the shop is closed for the day but
they leave the TVs in the window on all
night the electricity bill is going to
be outrageous right
whistling while on public transit Zelda
actually seems to be trying to remove
something here so it brings up the
serious question of how there's this
much dust on the underside of this
fuselage oh damn we sure are getting a
solid round of Brewster's positioning
hasn't this come up before in their
conversations ah sudden generals up
cleaning lady at a top-secret facility
freely touches the tank while their
superiors are in the same room and
doesn't think for one moment why that
might be an issue also do top secret
government facilities employ tons of
janitorial staff you have a lot of
Secrets flowing through this place and
you just trust your cleaners to keep
their mouths shut
this door open the whole time since
amphibian man arrived what kind of
secret facility is this yes pies for
breakfast just just trust me honest or
trust the judgment of people in this
packed diner that only serves pie and is
open early in the morning for some
reason I know Giles has a crush on the
Dixie pie guy but why does he keep
ordering this key lime pie I know he's
used his great love of key lime pie as
his conversation starter but you'd think
at some point he'd be like let me try a
new flavor and by the way this leftover
pie that takes all the space and Giles
fridge beginning to look like a shrine
Eliza and Giles are dicks to the people
trying to watch a movie downstairs
Lyndon Johnson now a man washes his
hands before or after tending to his
needs it tells you a lot about a man for
Michael Shannon's character they just
took lines from his Boardwalk Empire
character to substitute for Richard
Strickland I've never met a short man to
save nice all the way through that
shortest did you know there are a
billion janitors employed here but this
guy ran up a lunchroom to find the
proper staff to clean up a mess you will
have exactly 20 minutes to render this
this slab immaculately wait a minute
goddamn it the amphibian man just took
out one of the slabs most fearsome
employees but everyone's perfectly fine
leaving these two cleaners in here alone
this lab is so stupid that it's a wonder
the Russians haven't already completed
their secret plan this place is like the
Hellboy facility only before Hellboy
still has a say being in it played by
the exact same guy only without the
david Hyde Pierce voice Hellboy was
directed by someone famous - I can't
remember who it was and don't have the
willpower to look it up well I believe
you honey you sure it was alive Eliza
and Giles have probably developed a
pretty good way of communicating by now
but did she describe what she just saw
to it true free access for the cleaning
ladies to just walk into this room
whenever they please
if you can't trust your janitorial staff
who can you trust what purpose does this
tank windows serve whenever Strickland
is doing his thing and Philly a man is
out of the tank and the otherwise tether
him in the large section of the tank
I guess they included this just in case
he showed the ability to fall in well I
guess this is sign language for oh you
know just casually interacting with an
incredibly valuable violent and
otherwise unguarded possible fish got
you no siblings oh no sir that's not
common is it for your people
that's 1960 system they found it at the
river and no water of course they found
her in the water because this movie is
just one unhinge Dennis Hopper away from
being ghost directed by Kevin Costner
more on this informal meet Richard
Strickland the founder of cinemasins
it's a lot less religious these days I'd
drag that filthy thing out of the river
muck and South America all the way here
so basically a man were made for each
other because earlier zelda told us this
they found about the river and then
water that would make the people who run
the hotel and lobster very happy man
from being a major character in this
movie michael stuhlbarg is almost absent
for the first quarter up so much though
that when it does get to the reveal of
him being a spy I have no clue which
character he is damned Eliza has no fear
of getting fired either that or the
power of female boners is stronger than
the need for job security why the hell
are they mopping the exact same spot the
other person just mopped
you know Zelda and Eliza are together
for every other assignment so why is
everyone cool with letting Eliza do this
extremely important and secret room by
herself
geez did Eliza get so caught up and her
dance routine that she didn't see or
hear Michael stole bar from call me by
your name and the post come through that
door
which buzzes and beeps when it's opened
she should know by now that Michael
Stuhlbarg is everywhere and in
everything
copious cabbage caball worry about that
camera what's your mop head break time
and apparently nobody ever watches the
feed to see someone pushing the camera
to a different angle at the same time
every day this is a blind spot spot
shadowing
for instance I have to accidentally warn
Eliza than I'm about to open this door
then 100 percent of the things I had to
finish will be finished the one time
we've seen Eliza not take her cart into
the room happens to be the day
Strickland feels the need to get his
torture boner serviced you want to put a
man in space he's gonna have to endure
conditions the human body just wasn't
made for this gives us an edge against
the Soviets so the Americans went
through all this trouble to drag a sea
creature from South America because it
might help them with the space race man
we had all the time and money in the
world back then didn't we notice this MP
guy here well somehow Eliza runs out of
the room unnoticed mere seconds after
this and the MP guy isn't on the car so
he must still be in the room not doing
his job so crack the damn thing open
learn what you can and close up shop
here
general exposition waits to summarize
this conversation until they're out in
the wide-open area even though they went
all the way up to the cone of silence to
tell Hostetler what the plan was get him
out we have now officially entered the
Free Willy portion of the program he
sees me for what I am okay I've gone as
long as I can before taking a sin off
for Sally Hawkins amazing performance
especially here where she's acting her
ass off with no words and while we're
here Richard Jenkins is also great so
let's just remove two sins and move on
so I can start sending the fish the hell
you doin old man oh hey not the counter
takeout only you can't sit there holy SH
the pie guy went from adorable too
heartless bigoted in seconds flat what
would be a good time for you Bernie and
don't come back this is a family
restaurant I have no one I'm glad we
could take care of Giles - conflicts in
a whole 90 seconds so that he'll help
Eliza break amphibia man out of Ockham
prison Zilla Sh yeah mu idiots you
idiots you boob your shovel with a pink
syringe would it be easier to just
smuggle a gun in there and shoot it I
mean the Russians have to know that
thing bit Strickland's fingers off right
now no shiney american scene and Delia
Tavo shabu sheets yeah Betsy DeVos
Cadillac DeVille best car ever made and
it's really gonna be hard to make this
sale if he's got to stand on that
turntable the whole time I think this is
some of my best work
yes age 51 why the hell do they have
their ages listed on these ID cards
anyway especially since they already
listed their birthday also if it lies
are supposed to be 25 in this movie I'm
just saying I don't think she should be
throwing stones at Giles trying to pull
off if you want
I don't mind that you can't speak either
kind of gets me gone James Toback also
goddamnit we already know that
Strickland's evil from almost everything
he's done in this movie including buying
that Cadillac do we really need to see
him get all rapey okay yes he took a
survey of the stalls and found no one in
the but why would he do this out in the
open when anyone can walk in at this
very moment I want to be home early hang
on their ship ends at 4:30 they only
worked 4.5 hours a day I mean that kind
of skill was almost worth witnessing my
man tortured see I just don't see how
this isn't noticed after day a minute
ago we saw Strickland watching these
screens intently and yeah it's because
he's lusting after Eliza but you know an
asshole like this loves watching screens
for anything that's very smart you work
for
well yeah I guess in retrospect it
doesn't really matter all that much
since I'll never ask you this again
here you go this water must be kept at 5
to 8% salinity not that she can't know
what this means but does she know what
this means and she have the proper tools
in her apartment to ensure this
measurement and it sure is weird that
they have cameras in every room in this
lab except for the one with a super
amazing creature that should be watched
at all times what's that what's that
vehicle man who is suspicious about
laundry van still hasn't looked at the
camera that was obviously moved a couple
minutes ago so this is supposed to turn
off all the electric equipment for only
five minutes that's some hardcore damage
to the breaker box when the power comes
back on will it be emergency power or a
regular power because if it's emergency
power why wouldn't it come back on
immediately if it's a regular power then
this breaker box is why would they even
unwrap him isn't it better to keep him
buried in the towels for the clandestine
mission she's so beautiful
because there needs to be a
crowd-pleasing moment where a
Strickland's brand-new Cadillac gets
wrecked trials gets completely
distracted from the part of the task
that he's been dying to do since he
arrived get the fuck out of here did I
do that it's not very well known that
the then 42 year old Richard Jenkins
tried out for Steve Urkel on family
matters and it came down to either him
or Julia White none of the assholes
shooting at the laundry man try for the
tires and there is seriously nobody near
the exit yeah this should be 5 to 8%
salinity it passes the eyeball test no
no no anything really in a crowded
elevator Jesus can't anyone in the
secret lab properly secret what and I
doing interviewing the help well
technically only one actress from the
help but I see your point and it's
amazing the amount of this stuff the
fish man gets in this movie this is why
that revival of Alf never happened
luckily for eliza amphibian man left
convenient bloody handprints so that
eliza could track him like a discount
Aragorn and he didn't go far look I know
this theater isn't that popular but the
whole neighborhood was hoppin a few
nights ago not one mother on the street
saw him fibia man walking here and it's
at this point you realize she's really
gonna fuck that fish ever since Clark
Gable said I don't give a damn in Gone
with the Wind in 1939 Hollywood has been
trying to figure out how they could get
interspecies human amphibian King in a
movie and awarded Best Picture it took
78 long years but we finally did it god
dammit does he love meanwhile speaking
of Free Willy jealous depravity to every
other time Dimitri's met these guys
they've gone to a remote location smoked
some spice then went to the restaurant
so why are they literally coming over to
his house here doesn't that blow all the
covers Eliza says you know what I'm
gonna flood this entire apartment for my
sex life the theater downstairs doesn't
make money anyway also Eliza waits to
pull this stunt until the one time we've
actually seen patrons in this theater
yeah but if the cure for baldness was
gonna give John some hair why didn't he
give him all his hair back this is nice
but it's also a little half-assed I
guess you didn't care about at least
three people sneaking it because there's
at least seven people in this auditorium
I saw you giving free tickets Dylan Liza
earlier so maybe they also had free
tickets but if three of your seven
people got in for free does it really
matter at that point I've been dying for
a movie to recreate the underwater sex
scene and color of night and I finally
got it no wonder this one Best Picture
it gives everyone what they want
alien character suddenly becomes ill and
has to leave its new family to avoid
death cliche 36 hours from now this
entire episode will be over what the
hell is with the arbitrary timelines in
this movie I mean I know the general is
an asshole and he wants to get done
quickly but I thought this was an
extremely important asset shouldn't he
be doing everything in his power to
track that four down for as long as it
takes
unfortunately for Eliza her upstairs
neighbor just recently hooked up with a
giant sea squid and she tried the flood
sex technique and now Eliza has to deal
with unwanted water dripping into her
place it's poetic justice really back in
the 60s nobody was ready for big dick
alien fish on Broadway and it closed
after only one performance those
Philistines went away
look this is lovely and give Sally
Hawkins a chance to step out of her
character for a second but it's also a
jarring ass cut to a Long Island
alternate reality
whoa I didn't realize their name was
Octavia Spencer
I guess she changed it because there was
another actor in the guild named that
this candy it's cheap candy I love it
even though he's got very little time to
succeed in finding the asset and thus
avoiding I don't know whatever the
general threatened him with a few
minutes ago Strickland has time for this
what do you take Strickland goes after
zelda first despite the fact that Eliza
is definitely the most suspicious person
in the - but then again Strickland is
kind of racist so maybe he would I'm
still sitting this because it gives
Zelda the chance to warn Eliza who has
just enough time for empathy a man to
jump over her head into the water in a
dramatic slo-mo shot as Michael Jackson
starts singing he's coming Strickland
left the office prepared to bust
Hostetler and hasn't been back since
he's also strung the hell out on pills
so how does he know exactly where both
Zelda and Eliza lit Strickland notices
the note on the calendar and sees rain
docs
those could be any Doc's but he's going
to find the right one anyway also the
fact that amphibian man is dying on this
exact day that Demetri is being
extracted tonight that Strickland
finally got on the right track all on
the exact day that Eliza had scheduled
well in advance on her calendar and
Strickland can easily determine where
they're going is a coincidence sandwich
with extra luck sauce and a side a fluke
fries considering Giles ignores the gun
that is still clearly in the bad man's
hand I assume he too wants to get shot
and come back from the dead
hey it's a literal deus ex machina all
the police stand around watching two
people dying and do nothing it's kind of
like the real Baltimore oh good we get
to have our splash ending one more movie
this seemingly original film is like if
I told you about her what would I say
hopefully nothing during this beautiful
moment especially since you shut your
Yap for the last two hours but go ahead
and do your pros and your silly poem
poetry and prose it up
it was the lovely little fish it will I
get reported I come after you and the
music you do that Yolanda Yolanda it's
cool baby it's cool we still just
talking don't tap on the glass
now they go this way started waiting in
the line
[Music]
if you don't find that cheese-eating rat
bastard in your department it won't be
me who suffers was a fire the Chocolate
Factory I'm with and you know get the
hell out of my car did I stutter I think
I'll miss you most of all